YouTube what's up so so grateful that
you clicked and you're about to watch a
new youtube video but before you do -
one two nine three one five seven three
one that is my texting community
platform doing a lot of one-on-one
engagement in there and also access
opportunity first looks in that
environment - one two nine three one
five seven three one join it now and now
to the video you've been wanting to
watch hey guys I'm just listening
somebody was just talking post my
keynote and said how you do something is
how you do everything and I've heard
that a lot and I get it right which is
like be disciplined be good at the
process I actually just don't believe in
it at all likes it I actually think that
when you deploy self awareness and you
really get to know yourself that there
are certain things that you love so much
you go hard and there's certain things
that you don't like at all and you go
soft like I don't do entrepreneurship
the way I did school like so I actually
don't believe that I think it's an
important conversation I think we need
to have much more of a conversation it's
like self awareness like who are you
what are you about what do you like
what's your process are you creative are
you anal are you about the process sorry
about the money
alright like what what how are you
driven how do you work do you like I
like chaos and I need music to
concentrate you need a silent room we're
so so different
I actually think how you do the things
that you love the most is usually the
indicator of your happiness and success
[Music]
just landed here in Orlando boring
keynote going on right now which only
sets me up for a [ __ ] fire fest so
I'm excited about that and we'll [ __ ]
jump on a quick plane to Miami Miami to
London dominate in London for two days
London's Dubai dominate and goodbye for
two days back in New York land 8:25 in
the morning Sunday apartment shower how
are you we said thank you saying for
real means a lot to me it really does
I make content for and the way I grew up
was interesting and like I make
especially the kids I went to college
with real interesting like the kids from
your hood and like I make the content
for that person
[Music]
this is this is where I think you've got
a huge advantage when you come from
failure
then you shouldn't look like this is
what I'm trying to get yeah man this is
where I'm trying to go when I talk to
the streets I'm like [ __ ] what
the [ __ ] are you worried about failure
for you're not worried about failure
you're worried about judgment from your
other homies
it's not about failure it's about you
understand you I done lost like when
people like I'm iliza I was like I was
bad at sports I was bad at school I was
like I already lost they told me I
couldn't win that's exactly what you
grew up on the bigger thing is you might
be scared to lose in front of your
friends what are they gonna say you know
what I mean
that's where people get caught they're
not scared of losing especially from the
way you came up they're scared about
what their boys gonna say you know what
I mean that's why those are two separate
things that's why I always talk to you
don't always talking about like people
that have a lot of money they're more
unhappy than you think they're actually
scared of losing you know cuz they've
never done anything they've never stood
on their two feet and they're like
worried like wait a minute like they
know they're like that's mom's money
that's why I'm here on the flip side
people that come from the dirt they
already lost they're worried about
judgment they're worried about their
boys saying oh you trying to sell out
now no you're gonna be good now you know
all that [ __ ] you can't change like
people ms real of x' company and and
these are your best friends they don't
really want you to be miserable they're
just in such a bad place themselves that
they're scared that you might get good
and then they're gonna be by themselves
misery does love company that's real and
so I tell a lot of kids I'm like listen
your homies especially gonna keep
hearing me like oh [ __ ] it's my homies
that are [ __ ] me up and then I try to
flip it on him like listen don't be mad
at your homie your homies still just not
at that place that he's ready to [ __ ]
get his [ __ ] together she's not ready to
get our [ __ ] together so they may be
undermining you right now they might not
even be consciously doing that they're
just in so much pain still they wanted
they
to be with you still down here so it's
almost I got a compassion for them but
you got to recognize that's what you're
fearing
[Music]
[Music]
this goes back to judgment the reason so
many of you want to win right now so
fast is you want to show other people
you won this is why credit cards [ __ ]
everyone people want to buy [ __ ] they
can't afford to show people they're
actually winning versus action winning
my friends my friends we're gonna beep
this animation we're in a deeply deeply
complicated place where we always
worried about fronting and impressing
others and that used to be 13 people and
now we live complete public lives and
it's everybody
so it's compounded everybody's taking a
hike on the weekend for the Instagram
photo not for the [ __ ] hike people
right now is subconsciously you don't
even realize that you're doing it right
now if you took a step back you can't
imagine how much you're thinking about
your holiday vacation predicated on the
photos you post versus the vacation
itself we live in a world where people
yearn for affirmation or compliments
which makes them wildly vulnerable to
booing the reason so many of you
struggle and you don't post with a
negative hater or this is because you
over value compliments which make you
vulnerable to negativity this is
something we really need to start
talking about but why are you here like
why are we here today
look let me do
I'm some little [ __ ] like what are we
doing here I assume if you decided to
spend money on a would say Monday on a
Monday afternoon and listen to this [ __ ]
that you're looking for something which
is cool my curiosity is what because for
me if you're looking for tactics they're
so easy I've been telling you how many
people here follow me what you think
you're gonna get something crazy up here
today
you know exactly where I'm gonna [ __ ]
say I feel like Aerosmith up here I'm
not playing new music I'm gonna play the
[ __ ] classics but the reason I keep
like doing this and why it's interesting
to me is I've learned in the last decade
especially the kind of always new right
place right time right analogy right
moment right like to me it's been
fascinating to watch people consume my
content you know what's great about how
I do it and how I recommend you do it is
read your comments read your DMS read
your you know I know a lot of you're mad
I haven't texted you back I get [ __ ]
4,000 won a day I'm texting 300 back I
just can't [ __ ] catch up but I'm
telling you I read that [ __ ] and the
reason I read it is it allows me to know
what I need to talk about here you think
I knew that people were [ __ ] super
sad because their parents were paying
for [ __ ] I didn't know that my parents
gonna pay for my [ __ ] so I could have
never known that it was the thousands of
emails in the last five years that I've
read from kids in their 20s who finally
reconciled the fact of no [ __ ] my own
happiness comes from the fact that my
parents are secretly paying for my life
which consciously and subconsciously
makes me feel like a [ __ ] loser let
me tell you something right now you want
to get happy real real real fast I don't
know how many people this is gonna work
for in this room but if you're in this
camp if you are over the age of 22 and
your parents pay for anything on some
real [ __ ] you need to leave this
conference call your parents and say I'm
never taking another [ __ ] dollar from
you
[Applause]
there is nothing more obvious to me out
of all the listening I've done the last
half decade the thing I just said is
leading to a stunning amount of bad a
bad between the kid and appearance a bad
about that kid all they're doing is
taking that money to look like they're
doing something which starts corroding
you subconsciously in a way that you
cannot imagine I'm telling you living on
your own two feet is foundational to
happiness the resentment that you're
creating towards your parents and the
resentment that your parents are going
towards you is remarkable it's really
funny 40 year old crowd and higher and
go up you guys remember when we were
growing up if your parents were going to
help you you borrowed money you paid it
back we're not living there anymore and
that's amazing and I know parent listen
as somebody who grew up with not a
little and has it lot now I look at my
kids I want to but I want them to be
happy not look like they're successful
[Music]
I owe all my success no [ __ ] stuff
cause in a hotel I mean I've followed
you through it all like no [ __ ] I
know about your eating the wings the
whole line all the way back from Wine
Library Thank You Bayona College
downtown 50,000 students because no
[ __ ] thank you best gratitude I'm
happy I'm happy to meet you
[Music]
I followed your social I've been posting
like mad and I took my mortgage business
on the mortgage banker from 13 million
in 2017 and 546 million this year also
something I get it bro
real pleasure
[Music]
you know just landed in in Miami that's
a go catch this little shuttle for the
main airport headed to uh to London
good day good keynote got a lot done a
lot of Vayner sports a lot of
vaynermedia stuff logistically just a
grinding of the day gonna bang out on
email now for two-three hours
the mission
you